More than 5 million Americans are living with Alzheimer's disease, making it the most common form of dementia. There is no cure, but psychologists and other researchers have been studying ways to prevent Alzheimer's disease and other dementia-related disorders, including the use of brain training games and physical exercise. But do they work? In this episode, we talk with a psychologist who studies the effectiveness of these treatments. I'm Andre Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. Glenn Smith is a neuropsychologist at Mayo Clinic in Minnesota and a principal investigator of a study titled Comparative Effectiveness of Behavioral Interventions to Prevent or Delay Dementia. He is also a member of the American Psychological Association's Committee on Aging.
超过500万美国人患有阿尔茨海默病，使其成为最常见的痴呆症形式。目前尚无治愈方法，但心理学家和其他研究人员一直在研究预防阿尔茨海默病及其他痴呆相关疾病的方法，包括使用大脑训练游戏和体育锻炼。但这些方法有效吗？在本期节目中，我们采访了一位研究这些治疗方法有效性的心理学家。我是安德烈·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。格伦·史密斯是明尼苏达州梅奥诊所的神经心理学家，也是一项名为“预防或延缓痴呆的行为干预措施的比较有效性”研究的首席研究员。他还是美国心理学会老龄化委员会的成员。
His research focuses on not only treating dementia and Alzheimer's, but on how to prevent these brain disorders. Welcome, Dr. Smith. Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here. Some people can live 200. never show signs of dementia or other cognitive impairments. Others can be severely debilitated by these diseases in their 80s or even younger. What do we know about why certain people develop dementia, particularly dementia associated with Alzheimer's? Well, the honest answer is we don't know enough. We're trying to learn more about this issue of why some people have a predilection to develop
他的研究不仅关注痴呆症和阿尔茨海默病的治疗，还关注如何预防这些脑部疾病。欢迎您，史密斯博士。谢谢，很高兴来到这里。有些人活到200岁也不会表现出痴呆或其他认知障碍的迹象。而另一些人在80多岁甚至更年轻时就可能被这些疾病严重削弱。关于为什么某些人会患上痴呆症，特别是与阿尔茨海默病相关的痴呆症，我们了解多少？坦率地说，我们了解得还不够。我们正试图更多地了解为什么有些人倾向于患上
dementia. A few of the things we do know. We have some reasonable ideas about how the Alzheimer's disease develops in the brain. We believe the current theories are that there's a protein called amyloid beta that deposits in the brain and it seems that it's toxic to neurons, brain cells. And so amyloid deposition in the brain can lead to cell death and twisting and tangling of brain cell processes so you end up with the plaques and tangles of Alzheimer's disease. Now, one of the really challenging parts of the disorder is that the amount of brain pathology that accumulates seems pretty strongly correlated with the degree of thinking, cognitive, and functional impairments that people have. We've followed people from their
痴呆症。我们确实知道一些事情。关于阿尔茨海默病在大脑中如何发展，我们有一些合理的想法。目前的理论认为，大脑中沉积着一种叫做β-淀粉样蛋白的物质，它似乎对神经元（脑细胞）具有毒性。因此，大脑中的淀粉样蛋白沉积会导致细胞死亡，以及脑细胞突起的扭曲和缠结，最终形成阿尔茨海默病的斑块和缠结。现在，该疾病最具挑战性的部分之一是，大脑中积累的病理量似乎与人们所表现出的思维、认知和功能障碍程度有很强的相关性。我们每年对人们进行跟踪调查，从他们的
60s, 70s, and 80s annually with evaluations of their thinking and, and they're, and they're thinking and functioning. And we'll see two trajectories. Some people progress to cognitive impairment and dementia, and then they die, and they've given us permission to do autopsy, and those folks will have Alzheimer's disease or other pathologies. One in five people who've been in this longitudinal study, when they die, even though they remain cognitively and functionally normal throughout their life, they have plaque-antangled disease in their brain. So one of the intriguing, perplexing questions we're trying to understand is how is that possible? How did those people remain resilient to that amount of disease in their brain?
60多岁、70多岁到80多岁，评估他们的思维和功能。我们观察到了两种轨迹。有些人发展为认知障碍和痴呆，然后去世，他们允许我们进行尸检，这些人确实患有阿尔茨海默病或其他病理。在这项纵向研究中，五分之一的人在去世时，尽管他们一生中在认知和功能上都保持正常，但他们的大脑中却有斑块和缠结。因此，我们试图理解的一个令人困惑的问题是，这怎么可能？这些人是如何对大脑中如此多的疾病保持韧性的？
And psychologists, most notably a man named Yaakov Stern from Columbia University, have talked about this idea of cognitive reserve, the ability to show resilience in the face of brain pathology. So we're trying to understand more about what are factors that contribute to cognitive reserve and is cognitive reserve malleable. Can we enhance it somehow? Let's talk now about the research into the ability to prevent dementia onset. Are there drugs available? What about lifestyle changes? So on the medication front, there is, of course, a class of drugs that's approved for Alzheimer's disease. Now, this class of drugs has the effect of impacting level of of the neurotransmitter acetyl cooling in the brain.
心理学家，最著名的是哥伦比亚大学的雅科夫·斯特恩，提出了“认知储备”的概念，即在面对脑部病理时表现出韧性的能力。因此，我们正试图更多地了解哪些因素有助于认知储备，以及认知储备是否具有可塑性。我们能以某种方式增强它吗？现在让我们谈谈关于预防痴呆症发作的研究。有现成的药物吗？生活方式的改变又如何呢？在药物方面，当然有一类药物被批准用于治疗阿尔茨海默病。这类药物的作用是影响大脑中神经递质乙酰胆碱的水平。
That class of drugs was created from an earlier model of how we thought Alzheimer's disease develops, and those class of drugs, while their FDA approved for Alzheimer's disease, have proved to have limited effectiveness. On the lifestyle front, the notion is emerging that what's good for the heart is good for the brain, so all those things that we've tried to attend,
这类药物是基于我们早期对阿尔茨海默病发展机制的理解而创造的，尽管它们被FDA批准用于治疗阿尔茨海默病，但已被证明效果有限。在生活方式方面，一种观点正在兴起，即对心脏有益的东西对大脑也有益，所以我们一直试图关注的那些事情，
to on the public health front to reduce the risk of stroke and heart attack seem to have utility in reducing the risk of dementia as well. That includes things like physical activity level, diet, and notably now some evidence that certain patterns of cognitive engagement, your lifestyle around cognitively stimulating activities also seem to be associated with dementia risk. So people with more advanced levels of educational attainment or people that have engaged perhaps in their lifetime in learning musical instruments or foreign languages
在公共卫生方面，为了降低中风和心脏病发作的风险，似乎在降低痴呆症风险方面也同样有效。这包括体育活动水平、饮食，值得注意的是，现在有一些证据表明，某些认知参与模式，即你围绕认知刺激活动的生活方式，似乎也与痴呆症风险有关。因此，受教育程度较高的人，或者一生中可能参与学习乐器或外语的人，
or those kinds of cognitive enrichment activities seem to be at lower risk. So if someone has already noticed signs of dementia, is it too late to engage in some of these treatments? Well, we don't think so, and that's really the genesis of that research project that you mentioned, that we were fortunate to have funded by an organization called the Patient-Centered Outcomes Research Institute. We're trying to see if it's possible to, as I mentioned earlier, to impact this notion of cognitive reserve. So there is research to suggest that even if you already have the condition called mild cognitive impairment,
或从事这类认知丰富活动的人，患病风险似乎较低。那么，如果有人已经注意到痴呆症的迹象，现在参与这些治疗是否太晚了？我们认为并不晚，这正是你提到的那个研究项目的起源，我们很幸运获得了“以患者为中心的结果研究所”的资助。我们正试图看看是否有可能，正如我之前提到的，影响这种认知储备的概念。因此，有研究表明，即使你已经患有轻度认知障碍，
There is some research to suggest that those folks, those people who engage in those lifestyle modifications even after they've developed the diagnosis of mild cognitive impairment, at least have a longer time to progress to the full dementia syndrome. What about these adult brain training games? They're really popular right now. You see ads for them. Do they have any scientifically measurable effect on cognition or men? Well, they do, and it's an interesting time in that regard because a group of scientists in this area have just put out a statement that has been associated with the Stanford Center for Longevity,
也有一些研究表明，那些即使在被诊断出轻度认知障碍后仍参与这些生活方式调整的人，至少能延长发展为全面痴呆综合征的时间。那么这些成人大脑训练游戏呢？它们现在非常流行。你到处都能看到它们的广告。它们对认知或记忆有任何科学上可测量的影响吗？它们确实有，而且在这个领域，这是一个有趣的时期，因为该领域的一群科学家刚刚发布了一份与斯坦福长寿中心相关的声明，
cautioning the general public about the utility of these kinds of tools. But I think the meta-analyses of these different programs suggest that there is some measurable signal of cognitive improvement on certain of these programs that have been developed, especially those that target processing speed, because processing speed is what changes as we age. And as we age, we know this is kind of the fundamental deficit that normally aging people have. So imagine being introduced to four people at a cocktail party. No matter if you're 35 or 85, someone's probably going to introduce you to those four people at the same rate. And at 35, you'll be better able to hear that name.
提醒公众注意这类工具的效用。但我认为，对这些不同项目的荟萃分析表明，在某些已开发的程序中，确实存在可测量的认知改善信号，特别是那些针对处理速度的程序，因为处理速度会随着年龄的增长而改变。随着年龄增长，我们知道这是正常衰老的人所具有的基本缺陷。想象一下在鸡尾酒会上被介绍给四个人。无论你是35岁还是85岁，别人介绍这四个人的速度可能是一样的。而在35岁时，你将更有能力听清那个名字。
At age 85, you can do all those same tasks, but since they occur at a slower rate, by the time you get to the fourth person, you may not have the capacity to process it as deeply or as richly. So that's what gives people the experience of perhaps having memory failure. Why can't I remember that fourth person's name? I used to be able to do that. And it's not really a memory failure so much. So a number of these different computer training programs are targeting that aspect of brain functioning.
在85岁时，你可以完成所有相同的任务，但由于它们发生的速度较慢，当你介绍到第四个人时，你可能没有能力像以前那样深入或丰富地处理它。这就是为什么人们会有记忆力衰退的体验。为什么我记不住第四个人的名字？我以前能做到。这其实并不是真正的记忆力衰退。因此，许多不同的计算机训练程序都在针对大脑功能的这一方面。
And what they tend to do is first, and the critique of them is first primarily, What they make you better at is playing computerized brain games. But a few studies have shown some transfer to other areas of working memory. In our study, people did report better functioning in their daily life, but better functioning in your daily life is really hard to measure. Now, all of this as it pertains to prevention of dementia, gets a little more complicated because certainly,
它们倾向于做的是，首先，对它们的批评主要是，它们让你变得更擅长玩电脑大脑游戏。但一些研究显示，这种能力可以转移到工作记忆的其他领域。在我们的研究中，人们确实报告说日常生活功能有所改善，但日常生活功能的改善确实很难衡量。现在，所有这些关于预防痴呆症的内容变得有点复杂，因为当然，
we're not at a place where we can say Glenn Smith, if he does brain training games for the next 25 years, we can guarantee that he won't get dementia. But, you know, prevention as a concept is a concept that we really apply at the population level. And similarly, in my opinion, if we engage both physical activity and cognitive stimulation, including these brain training games in a population-wide level, we have the potential to see fewer numbers of dementia in the population at large. And that's really the kind of prevention we're talking about. So one of the challenges in this area is really what do we mean by prevention?
我们还没有达到可以说“如果格伦·史密斯在未来25年里玩大脑训练游戏，我们就能保证他不会患上痴呆症”的地步。但是，你知道，预防作为一个概念，是我们真正应用于人口层面的概念。同样，在我看来，如果我们能在全人群范围内参与体育活动和认知刺激（包括这些大脑训练游戏），我们就有可能看到人群中痴呆症病例的减少。这才是我们所说的预防。因此，该领域面临的挑战之一是，我们所说的预防到底是什么意思？
You know, we can prevent polio in a person by giving them a vaccine. We're certainly not at that level in the area of dementia, but we can prevent the numbers of cases of heart attack and stroke by eliminating smoking and improving physical activity and diet. And I believe that that potential is there in the area of dementia as well. Well, great. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Smith. This has been very, very informative. Thank you.
你知道，我们可以通过接种疫苗来预防一个人的脊髓灰质炎。在痴呆症领域，我们肯定还没有达到那个水平，但我们可以通过消除吸烟、改善体育活动和饮食来预防心脏病和中风的病例数量。我相信在痴呆症领域也存在这种潜力。太棒了。非常感谢您加入我们，史密斯博士。这非常有启发性。谢谢。
My pleasure. Thank you for the opportunity. For more information on dementia and Alzheimer's disease, visit our website at Speaking of Psychology, With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的荣幸。谢谢你给我这个机会。欲了解更多关于痴呆症和阿尔茨海默病的信息，请访问我们的网站《心理学谈话》，隶属于美国心理学会。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。